aujourd'hui on vous emmène au bout du
monde plus précisément au biotope du
bout du monde à epône il s'agit d'un
site où l'on peut observer une grande
diversité d'oiseaux là on peut observer
donc c'est une espèce
qui s'appelle la foulque macroule on
peut voir un adulte et deux petits en
termes d'oiseau on va retrouver donc on
peut retrouver plus de 200 espèces donc
en tout cas c'est ce qu'une étude entre
2010 et 2020 a suivi du site par des
naturalistes locaux a permis de mettre
en évidence c'est qu'on avait une grande
diversité d'espèces d'oiseaux qui
pouvaient s'y retrouver le site abrite
aussi trois cent quarante espèces de
flore différentes et pour préserver
toute cette diversité l'entrée est
strictement interdite au public le fait
d'entrer son public va entraîner un
dérangement notamment pour les oiseaux
lors de la nidification
lorsque les oiseaux par exemple les
hivernants vienne vienne passer l'hiver
sur le site également ils ont besoin de
30 tranquillité donc les gens sur les
berges vont les faire décoller voilà ça
va déranger perturber la nidification
il ya également des espèces de plantes
fragiles donc l'appareil le risque d'une
sur fréquentation du site peut engendrer
bien une disparition de certaines
espèces pour les plus curieux il est
possible de faire le tour du site et
d'apercevoir les oiseaux grâce à trois
observatoires chacun d'entre vous aide à
reconnaître les espèces grâce à des
panneaux en ce moment alors le niveau
d'eau est quand même relativement pour
la saison et du coup
cette hauteur d'eau
fait qu'il ya moins de zones derbier qui
se sont développées on retrouve donc
principalement des espèces comme les
foulques les grèbes huppés on retrouve
également des espèces comme comme la
grande aigrette ou le héron cendré un
véritable havre de paix de 41 ha pour
les oiseaux à découvrir au bout du monde
dans les yvelines
[Musique]